what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will be breaking down the latest events
in the boku no hero story including the
biggest twist in the history of the
series and how this shocking and
heartbreaking revelation is going to
impact the rest of the story after five
years of waiting for the identity of the
ua trader to be revealed horikoshi first
trolled us completely with a blatant
misdirection and then he finally
revealed the trader's true identity this
was crazy so let's get into it if you
guys enjoy our boku no hero content and
you want to see more in the future you
know what to do just leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps with the youtube algorithm and
of course if you're new to the channel
or maybe you watch our videos but you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a quick favor and make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications by the way we've recently
partnered with itaikuji an online
retailer in japan that makes anime merch
that is normally exclusive to japan
available to fans all over the world
they have a wide selection of awesome
anime merch straight from japan
including an entire section on mha which
has some of the best mha figurines i've
ever seen along with a bunch of other
awesome stuff check them out the link in
the description and because we're
partnered with them you can now use the
coupon code anime opera 500 for an
instant discount every time you use the
coupon code you are not only getting
awesome merch at a discounted rate you
are also directly supporting this
channel so check them out link in the
description needless to say this video
will contain massive boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the new chapter
starts off with a quick training sesh
between bakugou and deku bakugo is
demonstrating his brand new technique
the one that he had mentioned in the
previous chapter and which he calls
cluster thanks to the training he
received at endeavour's agency bakugo is
now able to create sweat spheres and
fire off multiple shots at the same time
creating a powerful cluster of
explosions this move requires him to
produce more sweat so he wears his full
winter suit even in warm weather so that
he can get more sweat at his disposal
man sometimes i forget just how gross
bakugo's quirk is because it is also
very cool at the same time the man is a
sweaty mess and let's face it he
probably doesn't have great body odor
but he also produces incredibly badass
explosions and other epic attacks so you
can't hate on that quirk either you also
have to respect bakugou for working as
hard as he does to get strong enough to
keep up with deku i mean deku and
shigaraki are now in a completely
different league than basically anyone
else in the story and yet bakugou simply
refuses to be just a supporting
character it will be fun to see how he
can actually contribute to the big
fights that are definitely coming very
soon todoroki is also training hard and
getting stronger although his main focus
is dabi rather than shigaraki and all
for one he wants to take down his older
brother so he has been working hard to
control both sides of his quirk in a way
that will make him resistant to dobby's
flames he is currently on the brink of
merging the two halves together into one
cohesive hole and it will be extremely
cool to see what todoroki will be
capable of when he fully masters both
sides of his quirk i don't think that he
will ever be on the level of decon
shigaraki but i do think that he and
bakugo will be strong enough to make a
real difference in the final battle
then we see mineta and kaminari having a
discussion about what is the best way to
proceed from here kaminari is wondering
if maybe the heroes should strike now
and strike hard because both all for one
and shigaraki are currently weakened and
of course the other massively powerful
villain gigantomachia is still being
sedated and he is imprisoned inside a
custom holding facility because of that
it seems like the odds may never be more
in the hero's favor than they are right
now but then sweaty boy jumps in and
tells kaminari that he is wrong on three
points first finding all for one in
chikaraki is a lot easier said than done
all for one is a criminal mastermind
he's been around for like a century and
he knows how to stay hidden he has been
extremely careful up to this point and
he's not going to slip up now then momo
adds the second point during their
previous battle against shigaraki he was
still incomplete and even during his
battle with stars and stripes he was
still not quite at full power if by the
time they find him shigaraki happens to
be at full strength that would
completely change the calculation
furthermore there are a lot less heroes
now than there were during the battle of
jakku as we know some were killed during
the war a bunch more were injured and a
very large number retired after the war
so while the villains may be weaker so
are the heroes
the third and final point is that the
villains will ultimately decide when the
final battle begins they will have the
element of surprise i mean everyone
knows where the heroes are and the
heroes have to operate close to where
people live because their job is to
protect the people meanwhile the
villains can hide wherever they want
they can bide their time and they can
strike at a time of their choosing this
places the heroes at a strategic
disadvantage by the very nature of their
job of being heroes deku is fully aware
of all of these factors and he vows to
head out soon so that he can do some
recon on the villains but then ida jumps
in and corrects him saying that deku
will not be heading out on his own
because he is no longer operating on his
own they will do it together as a team
and at the end of the day they will have
to work as a team because all for one is
still out there and who knows what else
he has in store for them oh and speaking
of what offer one has in store for them
the chapter then switches settings to
the woods outside the ua school but
within the ua grounds and this is where
the big traitor reveal is about to
happen toru is in the woods and standing
behind a tree for a while now she has
been extremely worried about a fellow
class 1a student who just hasn't been
the same after the battle of jakku and
while this wasn't strange in and of
itself because everyone was shaken up by
what happened during the war arc unlike
the other students this particular
student didn't even cheer up or smile
once after deku's return to ua toru then
overhears a conversation between three
people that is happening deep inside the
woods and within a surveillance blind
spot essentially this is one of the few
places on the heavily guarded ua campus
that is not being directly monitored by
cameras or security guards so that makes
this the perfect place for a very
private conversation as a result the
three people who are engaging in this
conversation clearly believe that they
can talk freely without anyone
overhearing them and the words that are
exchanged between them instantly changed
everything we thought we knew about the
ua trader the three people inside the
woods are yuga aoyama and his parents
and his parents are telling aoyama that
he has to keep following orders from all
for one just as he's been doing all this
time and there it is aoyama is the ua
trader aoyama is the one who has been
passing sensitive information about the
ua to the villains including the
location of the usj and of the secret
student training camp
but even though he is now confirmed to
be the ua traitor aoyama is not really a
villain it turns out that he is not a
willing ally of all for one he was
forced to follow all for one's orders
because all for one threatened to kill
his parents if he did not and that is
exactly what aoyama's parents are
reminding him of at this very moment all
for one has just given them another
order and aoyama's parents are telling
him that he has to carry it out if he
wants them all to be safe from all from
one's wrath they are also telling him
that as long as he's careful no one will
suspect that something is off and he
will get away with it just as he has all
this time toru can't believe what she is
hearing aoyama has been working for all
for one since before he joined the ua
and he has been spying on his classmates
all this time he has been passing
sensitive information to the villains
information that put his friends and
classmates in direct and serious danger
but even though this is a terrible and
shocking revelation it's important to
emphasize that in this moment aoyama is
crying profusely he clearly isn't happy
about the fact that he is the ua traitor
in fact he hates it and he feels
tremendous guilt because of it but he
has been blackmailed into it and clearly
his parents have been actively
pressuring him to comply with all for
one's orders we then get a quick
flashback that reveals more critical
information about aoyama's tragic
origins and how he came to be the ua
traitor aoyama was actually born
quirkless and this made him an outcast
from what we know about his parents it
seems that they are quite wealthy and
cultured and that aoyama grew up in a
high-end posh environment it is possible
that among the wealthy elite in the
world of mha being born quirkless is
looked down upon even more severely than
in the normal world that's because
elites tend to pay even more attention
to things like social expectations
etiquette and fitting in aoyama was
miserable because he had no quirk and
his parents didn't want him to be
shunned by the rest of society that said
it's possible that they also felt
embarrassed about their son's quirkless
status and that they were afraid that
they themselves would be shunned on
account of their son so aoyama's parents
went to all for one and they asked the
villain to give their son a quirk all
for one then gave him naval laser which
explains why aoyama had so much trouble
controlling it and why he needed a
special belt just to keep the power in
check he was not born with this quirk
the quirk was not compatible with his
body and that is why he hasn't been able
to fully control it at least not yet
alyama's parents claim that if they had
the opportunity to do it all again they
never would have asked for all for one's
help but now that they did it's already
too late once all for one helps someone
they are under his control forever and
so aoyama has no choice but to keep
leaking information to the villains for
his part aoyama continues to cry clearly
devastated by his predicament he has
been feeling so much guilt this entire
time and it took all of his willpower
not to expose himself and just come
clean about everything he had been
trying to put on a brave face and act
like nothing was wrong and after all for
one was captured at kamino and sent to
tartarus aoyama dared to hope that his
obligations towards all for one would
finally be over and that he could just
be a normal student like everyone else
aoyama continues sobbing as his parents
apologize for everything and beg him to
keep protecting them toto then decides
that she has to tell the teachers about
what she just heard but before she can
do anything deku shows up deku then
walks right up to the aoyamas and asks
them if he and toru heard correctly is
yuga aoyama really the ua traitor the
parents try to act dumb and they say
that deku must have misheard something
but yuga aoyama is done he's had enough
of the lies and deceit and with tears
flowing down his face he comes clean
about everything he admits that he
helped the villains during the usj
incident and at the training camp as a
shocked deku looks on aoyama calls
himself a dirty villain and that is how
this chapter ends
wow this was both shocking and
heartbreaking i mean i know there are a
lot of people out there who believed in
the aoyama trader theory for a very long
time such as the youtuber vocal
pineapple for example but i really don't
think that the people who believed in
this theory were in the majority my
impression is that a lot more people
believed in the toru traitor theory so
after horikoshi first trolled us with
toru this was definitely a shocking
reveal and with how much aoyama clearly
regrets that he was forced to become the
traitor it really is a tragic story that
we are witnessing aoyama is not some
evil villain who is living a double life
and who has been skillfully pretending
to be a class 1a student he would love
nothing more than to be a normal student
but his dark past has kept him in chains
this entire time aoyama really seems to
be genuine when he says that he was
feeling guilt and regret about all of
this and there were moments in the past
where it almost seemed like he was
trying to get caught i won't talk about
all the different clues that we had
about aoyama being the traitor because i
talked about that in my previous mha
video on the chapter 336
leaks i will link that in the
description and of course other
youtubers like vocal pineapple have also
made entire videos on that topic all in
all i can sympathize with aoyama to an
extent he was in a very difficult
situation that said what he did was
extremely dangerous even if he was just
trying to protect his parents by leaking
that info he placed his friends and
classmates as well as other heroes and
the ua teachers in serious
life-threatening danger people could
have died because of the intelligence
that he leaked and that includes his
classmates so now that aoyama has come
clean how will everyone react to the
truth will they all hate him will they
support him will he be redeemed
definitely let me know in the comments
how you think class 1a and the teachers
will react to the traitor reveal
personally i think that it will probably
be a mixed bag people like deku ochako
and tsuyu will probably be pretty
understanding about aoyama's difficult
position but i think that other people
like bakugou mineta and ida will be very
angry that someone would betray their
trust in this way a lot of what happens
next will depend entirely on aoyama if
he chooses to switch sides and helps the
heroes against the villains by using his
unique position as the traitor he may in
fact be redeemed in the end if all for
one believes that aoyama is still
working for him this would allow the
heroes to give fake intel to the
villains and maybe even lure them into a
trap but then again all for one is a
very very smart guy so i don't think
defeating him will be that easy and i
don't know about you guys but even
though aoiyama seems to be genuine in
his regret i think that his parents are
still kind of suss i mean i get that
they are afraid of all for one but the
way that they pressured their own son to
continue being the spy definitely made
my spidey senses tingle after all these
people knew how to get in touch with all
for one in order to ask him for a quirk
in the first place now i don't think
that all41 is just hanging out on social
media and you can dm him when you need a
quirk so this tells me that aoyama's
parents may have had some shady
underworld connections even before they
made the deal with all for one i'm
thinking that even if aoyama repents
completely his parents may still
secretly betray the heroes so we have to
watch them carefully now i want to hear
your thoughts down in the comments what
did you think about this crazy traitor
reveal and how is this going to affect
the story moving forward will the class
1a students ever forgive aoyama and is
there something sus about his parents in
all of this don't forget to leave your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more in the future just leave a
quick like it only takes a second but it
helps a lot and if you're new to anime
opera or maybe you watch our videos but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you really have to
go through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
anime opera quick reminder to check out
itaikuji link in the description every
product that you order with our coupon
code anime pro 500 directly supports
this channel as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see us peace cowboys
[Music]
you